cette future bâtir fincad a montré qu'il
était vraiment qu'aux médias et pas
seulement un comique voilà oui mais
quand on est comique on est on est
forcément comédien mais parce que même
si on fait même vitesse de l'habitat ce
qu'on joue de la guitare et sa quéquette
on joue la comédie quand même c'est
clair vous avez une guitare ou pas non
mais c'est un film c'est un film très
classique à un peu style cinéma des des
années 40 et d'ailleurs le scénario
reprend la trame d'un film qui est
normalement au succès qui s'appelait la
voilà qu'à ce jour aussi bien des
éléments avec noël noël qui est sorti en
45 été vu par 5 millions de gens et
bharati le réalisateur avait vu le film
en noir et blanc à l'âge de 7 ans sur la
télé ça sa grand mère à l'époque il
avait adoré il a repris cette trame pour
faire son film et c'est vrai que jugnot
c'est un très bon choix parce qu'il est
passionné aussi géorgie au partizan et
il a fait ce film qu'on adore ce
monsieur batignole dans lequel il a fait
jouer
jean paul rouve way et je trouve que
j'étais un peu dans la même position
croupe dans dans monsieur batignole
c'est à dire vous interpréter des
personnages très classique du cinéma
français césar is able ça me fait bien
plaisir c'est vrai tous que gérard
m'avait un petit peu justement parlé de
sa rencontre avec jean-paul et tout ça
il commet lui il est allé chercher jean
paul et comment voilà c'est pas le film
de gérard jugnot évidemment ouais mais
girard est vachement accueillant sur un
tournage quoi il connaît la difficulté
justement qu'on peut avoir new legend
côte sketch à la télévision de se
retrouver sur un plateau de cinéma
façades et des vrais acteurs de cinéma
et tout ça deux voilà ensuite moins
génial c'était c'était
voilà c'est des gamins enfin on a passé
des moments avec les gosses super quoi
céder étaient tous habillés comme dans
le film d'ailleurs c'était marrant on se
retenant mais pas ce que je vais dire
mais c'est pareil mais ce que je vous
dis non mais on était on était en
tournée dans un château en fait on était
vraiment en milieu très clos comme ça on
à part quelques avions qui passait qui
nous rappelait qu'on était way en 1990
si vous étiez regarde ce qu'est ce qu'il
raconte et en essayant 49 espèces de
moment et puis moi c'est mon premier
film où j'ai un vrai personnage un vrai
rôle et tout ça est donc j'étais très
très ému il est très content et oui et
puis surtout l'aventuré avec christophe
barratier dont j'avais fait un peu son
court métrage c'est vrai les tombale
vous aviez fait ça mais c'est absolument
vrai nom mais c'est super voilà belle
histoire donc vous êtes seul sans
olivier et en plus vous avez repris
votre nom de famille donc merad et pas
repris ouais je les jeux les plus jeunes
les jamais oui mais moi j'ai remis sur
la fiche ça veut dire quoi quand on
remet son nom parce que la dernière
personne que j'ai vu faire ça et c'était
pas complètement innocent cd zabou
breitman elle s'appelait zabou et un
jour elle s'est appelée breitman et ça
veut dire quelque chose mais je sais pas
bien on s'assume plus non on commença à
être moins discret sur ses origines
parce que oui donc je ne vois pas ce
qu'il y'a une époque où tout le monde
revendique sa communauté d'origine
vous avez été super discret là dessus en
fait on vous a jamais entendu prendre
parti pour rire et je vais commencer et
je suis contre les volcans les lutteurs
dangereux non non mais si oui mais voyez
par exemple quand j'étais plus jeune et
j'ai commencé à faire de la radio
je mets mon prénom c'est kaddour kaddour
merad ans après l'on est d'origine
algérienne ce que mon père est d'origine
algérienne est née le 27 mars 64 à sidi
bel abbès en algérie
il fournit en californie voilà
maintenant il y en a une à deux il faut
l'admettre en algérie et sidi bel abbès
qui est jumelée avec sidi bel abbès
c'est vrai que si c'est la première fois
que vous parlez de vos origines jusqu'à
présent j'étais super discret non mais
voilà mais en même temps je vais pas de
j'ai pas de problème avec ça
j'en ai eus quand j'étais plus jeune
parce que quand je m'appelais cadeau et
que j'ai commencé à faire la radio le je
me suis que le directeur d'antenne m'a
dit voilà kaddour sur une radio fm en
banlieue ça va pas le faire donc on va
trouver à trouver une autre solution et
on m'appelait cad mr canon vient mystère
qu'elle s'appelle alliée à la bbc à
lumio levier et donc ses cadets rester
tout ça et puis bon en même temps moi
j'ai jamais été mon père est français
d'origine algérienne j'ai des racines
algériennes j'ai pas une je suis pas
comme vous et à bobigny alors enjoint la
ma mère est française du berry on n'a
jamais à part oui tout à fait je fais un
truc super important la saison
non non non mais je ça me dérange pas à
part le fait de ne pas manger de porc à
la maison c'était le seul
alger algérie nation qui avait chez nous
au financement et le matin mon père
quand il faisait le couscous si la
musique arabe qui grands traits qui
monte jusqu'à ma chambre
voilà der midi quand je n'en avais qui
continue à faire le couscous mais à part
ça il n'y a jamais eu de 2 oui on m'a
jamais gélules de relégation des récits
voilà on n'est pas musulman et je n'ai
pas de religion j'ai simplement des
racines très très fort même
à l'adolescence quand vous vous posez
des questions oui c'est dans le désert
algérien que vous partez réfléchir oui
parce que j'ai de la famille en algérie
et donc c'est facile d'aller en algérie
je suis fasciné par le désert est là et
par le parquet sable et en revenant
d'être une grande décision
attention les gigolos brothers au club
assez utile utiliserait son désert et a
raccourci d'accord
non mais vous faites aussi andromaque
avec jacqueline duc prend des cours de
théâtre tout légère classe les gens ne
savent pas mais non ben ouais mais
maintenant ils vont le savoir
oui alors voilà donc j'ai joué j'ai fait
du théâtre maison misanthrope
elle sait ce qu'est pendant cinq actes
sur une scène à ville d'avray part au
travail sortir voilà monsieur chasse
tout ça j'ai fais quoi moi j'ai fait
beaucoup en cours quoi je vais remédier
c'était un cours qui la médiation du qui
n'est plus parmi nous nous nous donner
des cours en même temps à le monter des
pièces qu'on jouait vraiment devant du
public en banlieue parisienne j'ai envie
de la vraie c'est vrai tout ça l'abbé la
banlieue moi je me suis retrouvé
effectivement à jouer le misanthrope
voilà et oui et d'ailleurs je vais vous
faire un extrait provient quelques
verres ouèrè signalèrent ce que j'aime
beaucoup qui était inquiété une
déclaration d'amour de deux dalles c'est
ce qu'ils disent est à célimène
efforcez-vous ici de paraître fidèle et
je m'efforcerai moi de vous croire tél
on est content
ce qui fit la vague mais avec 120 cas
c'est fait c'est quoi c'est comme une
phrase d'une phrase de ruy blas de
victor hugo qui dit je pense à vous
comme l'aveuglent au jour
c'est beau moi j'aimerais bien parler
comme ça sauvian hulot et je dis que
c'est moi en général ou et tchèques des
mof et touchent pas bien je vais te dire
un truc mais efforcez vous de paraître
ici fidèle et je m'efforcerai moi de
vous voir tel titre est donc le reste de
la vie de cadets connu après aval à la
radio en présentant cet abruti c'est
n'importe quoi de la mer on connaît mais
c'est réglé jettera radio toi là il
alors il ya eu cette série d jean-michel
que j'adore plus que tout est évidemment
tout ce qui est jean-michel évidemment
moi je suis top clients et donc on va
vous faire une interview jean michel
jean-michel verbaux bonsoir dangereux
pendant cette question moi vous êtes
critique de cinéma
jean-michel verdot je crois vous avez vu
le film les choristes de christophe
barratier et que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup aimer un nom revient laurent
j'avais comédie moi j'avais beaucoup
aimé ce film jean michel jarre de se
remettre autre chose que de la vodka
s'il vous plaît je vais faire au
championnat et alors je vais répondre à
la manière de jean michel à peu près si
vous êtes fatigué il a trop bu
voilà je me suis alors valu autant je
vais faire du zèle sans vabre oui et
salut merci vingt et un autres via je
fais trop bien les personnels je vais
mettre un autre costume non non non non
mais on dit et jean-michel à peu près
par michel à peu près voilà oui bon oui
oui oui bon on va revoir et u2 est bon
et un synopsis scénario est imprimé
étape et est en hausse il ya dix ans les
cadres si vous avez appelé l'armée à peu
près
à peu près
jean-michel lequel jamie tient à peu
près alors ce qui n'a pas plu c'est
l'histoire c'est des acteurs c'est quoi
c'est là qu'il a trouvé trois cinq
heures six heures sept heures bon en
même temps et voilà allez une
avant-première et puis voilà je vais
critique jean michel enquête est ce que
oui est surtout affaire là maintenant et
toute ma famille pour cela c'est la
famille du côté de ma mère les
berrichons hélas et les algériens mon
père ça va
enfin
tiens ça c'est sûr qu'un album ça c'est
pas loin 16e
non mais bon je crois que les acteurs
articule mal on l'a on l'a on l'a bien
compris un jeu dans ce film et jugnot
vous l'avez trouvé comment jean michel
aulas est en fait oui comme d'habitude
voilà bon escient c'est jean-michel
touch 3g le fait déjà depuis tout à
l'heure je sais que c'est pas votre
métier mais est ce que vous pourriez
nous mieux chanter quelque chose a
cappella comme ça je sais pas du brel un
truc quoi chanter un truc ouais ouais
c'est si vous voulez web on est quoi je
t'invite je sais pas
un micro de la musique il faut une faute
du public il faut à l'épaule
à tokai ne me quitte pas frivole toi tu
vu tu chanter ton shampoing ne me quitte
pas il faut oublier tout peut s'oublier
qui s'enfuit déjà oublié le temps c'est
chiant quand tu as une gonzesse qui
mordait la compétition mondiale c'est
sale et le temps perdu je m'en fous je
vais jusqu'au bout la shoah dure cinq
heures savoir je vais faire dans tous
les pays du monde le brésil faute
science okasana mai à auch to fly the
use du mazet tâche et a bombardé au
football omar cause des protèges cadence
face aux young boys palabres
san mamés au canada qui ne va pas
d'attentes un moulin
ouais ouais
je parle de cause